だいぶマシにはなりましたがまたカズ君ですはじめ社長です
はいみなさん今年ももうちょびっとですねもう1週間もないんですよ皆さん今年いかが
でしたか僕今年
にゃんまり楽しくなかったら楽しかったですよろしかったですけど全体的な生活の質と
レティを裏へ
を考えるとあな生活の質は覚えたいわけなかった
お菓子術禁止のせいでこっちはちょっと体調のことを考えてちょっと食べすぎてダメだ
なと思ってたんで今年はとりあえず禁止しようと思って何とかおかしいジュースを禁止
してここまで来たんですけども
やっぱね食べたいものが食べれないっていうわけで辛くて精神的に厳しい自然でした
よくがんばったはじめうううううてで今日ですねあの北
10月軽視しているときに何を飲んでたかというとあーんすいう基本的に毎日飲んで
ました
その基本的に炭酸ジュースが好きなんですがコーラとか悪口らもうちょいの面じゃ
オランジーナのかーっ
もう1週間は数字で乗れるんだよって僕を単3形の充填が大好きでそれを禁止してる
地点でも今年ば法案を終わってるもんですね今年はもう割るとし
でしたそれで別楽だったんですけどもうその辛い中でも少しでも気を紛らわせるために
僕は離さ薄いという無未使用車するゾンデたわけですよ今日のために炭酸水を果たして
落とし1年で何今何とかっていうのを調べようと思ったらで奥が乗ったターン制のゴミ
は基本的に全部とってあります本当だったからそこによるやってること多いんですよ一
回簡単にごみと間違えられたんです
何十歩捨てられたんで僕宮こと車飲んだ炭酸水の数が決まると思いますちょっと数えて
いきましょう
もう呼吸をするように飲んでたから多分ヤバいと思ってる
ターン制の量は
[音楽]
これもってきた中でもまだ半分も入ってませんからね
これだろ津久井な余裕で超えますなぁ全然足りないと気がしてきた
あーも多分机の上ず無理だろちょっと下にひいていきます
敗北は1年でこれだけを端正になりました
かな方+5本だからセカンド403104ずーっとチェック
[音楽]
あれここにあるの全部とプラ製チップ飲むから+後ぐらいにしとくと
240本でございました
[音楽]
ん
follow ている少なくねでも母さんに結構捨てられてるからそれを含めると多分
わかんない300ぐらいはいってると思いますあれ全10本飲んでねーぞ
束にそこってたのがたまにサボってたんだたまにサボってたごめんなさいまあ一音十方
は嘘だったんですけどもうこの量は確実に飲んでます240本でしょ
一方500ml だから120 l ですよ
ぐ20リットルは僕は炭酸水を飲んでいることになります少なくともってお腹すぐたず
熱い体にいいらしいので僕はやってよかったと思います声なんかほんとこいつと歩んだ
1年だった今年は炭酸水があったからこそ僕は健康でいられたのかと思います1年が
炭酸水生活をしてみて思ったことは
コーランの見て
me
[音楽]
あっはっ